well for iq siblings correlate about 0.3
in childhood about 0.4
later on how much do these adoptive sibs
correlate because they grow up in the
same family they have the same parents
zero so the fact of growing up in the
same family
isn't making them similar
you turned my world upside down last
year when i read
blueprint i i i've been
looking forward to speaking to you ever
since i read that book and
i'm hoping that today i'm going to be
able to deliver the same
uncomfortable topsy-turvy world that i
was
i sort of slowly ingested about 12
months ago so i'm looking forward to
seeing what the audience make of the
insights that we're going to get from
today
yeah well that's that's terrific that
you got it you know
i some people i think just get turned
off they just say
whoa this is too weird but um it is
really
so rewarding for me when people you know
persist with
it they're willing to deal with these
difficult topics and then when you get
off on the other side
it isn't so bad it's actually exciting
it's a new way of seeing the world i
think
so that's terrific i'm really glad to
hear it totally correct like it is a
whole
new world and you're you're also right
to say that
today there'll be some uncomfortable
insights especially when we're in a
meritocracy
you know a meritocratic society that's
capitalist and you are your achievements
to hear that there are these immutable
truths
that you perhaps didn't choose there are
influences on you that you didn't elect
these things are uncomfortable but you
also correct that it's very liberating
if you take it
just a little bit further it's so
liberating to learn so okay we've
danced around it how would you describe
behavioral genetics to someone who's
never heard it before
well behavioral genetics is like medical
genetics it's not the genetics of
medicine
it's the genetics of behavior and
behavior is essentially psychology
so we're dealing with the major domains
of psychology like
psychopathology personality cognitive
abilities
even getting into education educational
achievement but the main thing is we're
focused
on individual differences why are some
people schizophrenic and others not why
are some children
reading disabled and others not and it's
an important distinction because um
genes we're 99.
say nine percent similar for all our dna
three billion base pairs of dna we have
exactly the same dna
at these are the steps in the spiral
staircase of the double helix of dna
we're identical for well over 99 of
those bases
but for at least 0.1 percent or so which
still means
millions of these steps in the spiral
staircase we differ
and so what we're asking in behavioral
genetics is
the extent to which those differences in
inherited dna sequences
make a difference in our behavior do
they make us more likely
to be susceptible to schizophrenia or
depression or alcoholism
or do they affect our personality so it
just can't be
emphasized enough that we're talking
about individual differences
the other 99.9 percent of the dna
is the same for all of us that's what
makes us human
and those are also important questions
you know is that
that is that why for example humans are
natural language users
or we walk on two feet which is very
rare we have eyes in the front of our
head
for depth perception so those are
questions about universals
why is the human species like this or
like that
those are terrific questions but we're
not looking at that we're asking
about why people differ and the extent
to which
inherited dna differences make them
different
it's crazy to think that all of the
differences that we have come down to
that
point one percent all of the
idiosyncrasies the way that we
speak the nature the texture of our own
mind the interests that we have any of
the
medical predilections that we have with
regards to our behavior
especially given that i've got a big
interest in evolutionary psychology
which is looking at that
99.9 and then your field just focuses on
the
tiny little final bit right
so it would be perfectly reasonable to
think that these
small amount of dna difference doesn't
make a difference
and psychologists always assumed
inheritance wasn't important they
from freud onwards assume that we are
what we learn you know it's the
environment that makes us who we are
and that's called nurture and especially
the family environment
you know when i was in graduate school
in the 70s textbooks actually said at
the time
that schizophrenia is caused by what
your mother does to you in the first few
years of life
and you know that's reasonable because
schizophrenic mothers tend to have kids
who are more likely to be schizophrenic
but what they didn't realize is that
parents in offspring are 50
similar genetically so the issue is to
what extent
do inherited dna differences account for
some of these differences we observe
and you don't need dna it was only in
the last 10 years we were able to use
dna
for the last hundred years we've been
able to use methods like the twin method
that compares identical and
non-identical twins
adoption studies where you study
genetically related people
reared apart like birth parents and
their adopted away children
or conversely then adoptive parents of
adopted children who share
nurture environment but not nature
and so the shock was in the 70s and 80s
that all of this evidence
kept coming up with a fi a general
finding
that in individual differences in
psychological traits
are very substantially due to genetic
influence
we now say about half of the differences
are due to
inherited dna differences and the
excitement now is with the dna
revolution
we're able to begin to find some of
those dna differences
which will allow us to make predictions
at the level of the individual
which is going to be a very big thing
fifty percent
fifty percent of the differences are due
to inherited dna differences now first
that means the other half
is not due to dna differences it's due
to the environment
but there's a big story there into that
the environment isn't what we always
thought it was so we can get on to that
later
but the we call it heritability the
extent to which
genetic differences make a difference
for a trait
and there's some important
when you say trait what's a trait oh yes
a trait is a measure of individual
differences
what would be an example like physical
height weight
psychological psychopathology
personality
okay so um when we say that these
that uh heritability is 50
we're talking about differences between
people so
the easiest one take weight people are
often surprised you say height how
heritable is height
well people aren't surprised to hear
it's very highly heritable
how highly heritable at least 90
so that means of the differences you see
between people in height
about 90 percent of the differences are
due to inherited dna differences
so the first misconception is that
that's not you you didn't grow
90 because of your genes and the last 10
percent
uh because of the environment and as
funny as it sounds
you scratch the surface of what people
know and most people are making that
mistake
so we're talking about differences
between people in the population
okay so highly heritable 90 but how
heritable
is weight say body mass index
um a lot of people think yeah maybe
there's a little genetic influence but
it's mostly due to the environment
and it's not it's 70 percent heritable
so of the differences you see between
people and weight about 70
of the differences are due to inherited
dna differences
so that's kind of shocking to people and
it makes
a couple of points one is again we're
talking about
differences between people in a
population
given their environmental differences
you know like some people are exercising
and watching their diet and all of that
and other people you know just let it
all go but
it's and given the genetics that's there
too different populations differ
genetically
you know there's immigration immigration
across time
we're just describing differences as
they exist
in a particular population at a
particular time
we're not talking about what could be so
with weight for example and this is the
second misconception if it's genetic
it's deterministic it's fatalistic and
that's true
of the thousands of single gene
disorders like if you have this mutation
in a gene at the tip of chromosome 4 you
know we have 23 pairs
of chromosomes our 3 billion base pairs
of dna are
chopped up into these 23 blocks we call
chromosomes
so at the tip of chromosome 4 there's a
gene for huntington's
disease which is what woody guthrie had
it's a
a long-term degenerative disease that
doesn't show up until later in life
so if you have that mutation for
huntington's disease
you will die from huntington's it is
deterministic hardwired
unless something else kills you first no
matter what your diet is there's nothing
you can do to prevent it
now so it is deterministic and that's
the way people learned about genetics
that's what mendel studied with his pee
plants
these are hardwired deterministic single
gene
necessary and sufficient disorders
however when we get to psychological
disorders and most common medical
disorders they're not like that
they're not due to a single gene they're
due to thousands
of tiny dna differences and that changes
the story
from determinism to probabilistic
propensities it gives you a risk so
um so that's the second misconception
and
go ahead sorry i'm rabbiting on you not
at all you've got a quote in the book i
think that summarizes this beautifully
and it says
dna isn't all that matters but it
matters more than anything else
and it matters more than everything else
put together in determining who we are
right well that's the heritability of 50
if you look across all psychological
traits
on average they're about 50 percent
heritable
physiological traits you know weight
more heritable seventy percent height
even more heritable i need to stop you
there the
heritability of weight being 70 percent
there are a lot of guys and girls
listening that do fitness there'll be
pts there'll be dieticians
that work incredibly hard to try and get
themselves to their optimal bmi to get
their athletes down to a weight and a
body fat percentage that they're
supposed to
and you're saying that the best diet
regime would have been to have different
parents
well absolutely i mean that would make
the biggest difference but see again the
point i was getting to here
is that we're describing what is in this
population
at this time with people some people who
are fitness nuts or
really watch their diet and all of that
and other people who don't we're saying
of those differences in weight how much
are due to inherited differences and the
answer is
more than half 70 on average across many
different countries for example
but it's also true in the uk it's about
70 heritable
now the point though the third point is
it doesn't it's
it's a confusion between what is and
what could be we're describing a
particular population we say on
average 70 of the differences are due to
genetic differences
for weight but that doesn't mean you
can't control your weight
your own weight it's it's what is in the
population
it's not what could be for one
individual most obviously
if i was locked in a room and not
allowed to eat i would lose weight
and it's part of the problem too is
people think you know i do have
we now have these genetic scores we can
predict about 10 percent of these
differences
in body weight with dna alone now
it's about 70 heritable so we've just
started doing this but you know
predicting 10 percent is not bad i mean
there aren't a lot of other things that
will predict
bmi to that extent so it you know it's a
start
right with this bmi so my highest risk
score
for what we call polygenic these dna
composite score
is for bmi so i'm really meant to be a
genetic
fatty but again you know people say oh
well you're just going to give up and
say you can't do anything about it but
you know to the contrary i find it's
very motivating
i know why i keep putting on it's
invidious you know i put on a few pounds
every year
but then you don't lose those pounds and
you know for
some of us they tend to go to the belly
and you know
and and you know people say well just
pull your socks up you know just
don't eat so much exercise more it's
easy for
thin people to say but if you have this
propensity
to put on weight um i think really what
it is it's not even physiological i
think it's psychological we've done some
research saying that
the genetic propensity is more um
we talk about satiety feelings
i go out with people eating at a
restaurant
pray god we can do it again pretty soon
but you know and
i'm full and but there's food on the
table we're talking away and before you
know it i've eaten that food
i'm not hungry well that's that's
totally correct because for even when
you're talking about particular traits
the individual ways that you can
contribute to that trait manifesting can
occur in a number of ways
let's say that um that 70 percent could
be contributed to from
some people who don't like exercise some
people who
do have great a ghrelin release or
leptin release or whatever in their
stomach that encourages them to feel
hungry maybe some of them have bigger
stomachs maybe
this particular selection of traits is
associated with having a larger stomach
or what pick your route moving forward
whatever it might be
they just have an all-or-nothing
mentality when it comes to food
no exactly right there's lots of
different ways in which these genetic
effects can come in
it's highly unlikely to be a simple
pathway it won't be
not everyone gets fat in the same way
that's right
and another major cue here that you
didn't mention is
um uh responsiveness to food cues
so you know i can't i used to like to
make bread
i can't do it because the smell of fresh
and my mouth is watering i'll just even
thinking
a fresh warm bread and the thought of
putting butter on it
it's irresistible to me you know and i
say irresistible i can resist it
but it's just other things being equal
they're not equal for me you know
i go past the bakery and i smell the
bread and stuff if i go in there i'm
dead you know
i can't help but buy these pastries you
know and it is sort of
free will in a way i mean people say
that but it's just on the fly in life
there's a lot of things impinging on us
and we're bombarded by food cues for
those of us particularly sensitive to it
so really all of this does come down to
suggesting
that people ought to cut us a bit more
slack
you know there's fat shaming that goes
on and people need to recognize
there's a very strong genetic component
to
how much weight people put on how easy
or hard it is to lose that weight
and so i think it does suggest um
that we uh you know are a bit you know
less judgmental
not just assuming i mean it is free will
but it's not
in the context of life it's constrained
well
yeah that's exactly right yeah so i find
i just have to avoid having junk food
don't walk past don't walk past the
bakery
you need to alter your route to work so
i think people
most people especially when you talk
about something like height or shoe size
oh yeah my dad's
my dad's a size 15 and mum's a size nine
so i
i had big feet as well people are kind
of accepting of that
i think that where it becomes more murky
is
behavioral traits right you know how
people manifest their
personalities their level of happiness
their depression their materialism their
status seeking whatever it might be i
think that do you find this when you're
trying to communicate it to people
um the nice thing about weight body mass
index you know which is weight corrected
for height
is that it's kind of in between the
hardcore physical things like height
which you know don't change much during
development i mean
you increase in height but you don't go
up and down in height the way you do
with weight
you know as i well know but um it is a
very psychological trait because a lot
of the mechanisms
involved in a lot of the effects are
psychological sorts of effects
so yeah what i like about it is no one
argues about how to measure weight
whereas when you get into psychological
traits a lot of it's based on
questionnaires like depression you know
someone would interview you and say
you know how many times have you had
these feelings or have you ever had
suicidal thoughts
and it's kind of self-report and
people say well but but that's today and
yesterday i didn't feel that way you
know it's much more dynamic
and you'd think harder to measure but i
would say for people who just dismiss
these psychological traits that
psychologists because they know it's
hard to measure these things has spent a
lot of time
measuring them and i think they do quite
well
and they find a lot of stability
for these things even depression which
goes up and down
but if you talk about depression over
the last year
that's going to correlate pretty highly
with your experience of depression 10
years from now
how do you study this let's say that one
of the first things that i
thought upon swallowing the huge
industrial sized red pill that i had to
reading your book was
yeah but i just had all of these
yearbooks in there yeah but how are they
studying this so what
how are you able to separate out all of
the different genetic influences on
traits well there's two questions there
one is how do we measure it the other is
how do we separate out genetics and
environment
on the first bit i would just say that
i particularly like to study cognitive
abilities because
you can measure them you know like
spatial ability and memory ability
and you can measure them accurately and
their maximum performance
you know so you take this test and you'd
be trying to do as well as you can do on
it
and your scores today will be highly
correlated with your scores
next month and next year they're highly
reliable these sorts of scores
the problem with other sorts of measures
like personality is
if i ask you how shy are you well
you think of oh but what context do you
mean so we try to ask questions about
many different contexts you know like
we're at a party with strangers
which is the kind of key aspect of
shyness
the shyest person on earth is not shy
with pers of someone they love they live
you know they live with or they they're
very familiar with shyness
anxiety doesn't enter into that so it is
difficult to measure but i
without going into it in great detail i
would just say
psychologists have spent a century
trying to measure these things
and i think they do pretty well at it
but now the issue of how okay so now
you've got to measure
i mean weight's easy people differ and
they for most of these traits they
differ in what we call
the normal distribution a bell-shaped
curve
so for weight there's some people who
are extremely obese
and there's some people who are
extremely thin most people are in the
middle
that's this bell-shaped curve that's the
individual differences that i'm talking
about
and if i use the word variance that's a
statistic
that describes the extent to which
people differ
the variance so you describe this
distribution with a mean
the average which is in the middle of
this bell curve
and then this statistic of variance
which describes the extent
to which people vary around that mean
because
a distribution i don't know if you can
see it here a distribution that
spreads out has a lot more variance than
a distribution that's
tight like this so
um so the way we study variants and why
people differ
as i mentioned involves methods from a
century ago
called the twin study which compares
identical
and non-identical twins so identical
twins are clones of one another
their dna is exactly the same
fraternal twins or non-identical twins
like any brother and sister
are fifty percent similar genetically so
of the dna that differs
at one percent they're similar for about
fifty percent of that
so if a trait's influenced by genetics
you'd have to predict that identical
twins
are more similar than non-identical
twins because they're twice as similar
genetically
so that's the twin method and the
adoption method's even more
straightforward
in families nature and nurture runs
together
so the fact that parents who are
schizophrenic have kids who are more
likely to be schizophrenic
it's always assumed to be nurture but it
could be nature there could be genetic
influences there
and one way to do to tell that is to
separate nature and nurture
so you can have birth parents who are
become schizophrenic later in life
who relinquish kids for adoption and
those kids are adopted away in an
adoptive home
where the parents are unlikely to have
schizophrenia
so that is a direct estimate of the
extent to which parent offspring
resemblance
is due to genetics and the converse side
of it
is just as neat you've got adoptive
parents
of adopted children they share nurture
with those kids they adopt them early in
life
so they're the environmental parents of
those kids but they're not genetically
related to those kids
so these two methods what's nice is
they're very different they each have
different
problems but the convergence of evidence
from both of these measures methods is
really very impressive
and so that's how we get to this
conclusion that across
if you take all psychological traits say
in twin studies
you get an average heritability estimate
of 50
which is just extraordinary given that
30 years ago
most psychologists would have said now
there's really no important genetic
influence
how many twins have you studied or how
many people have you used in these
adoption studies in these twin studies
am i right in thinking that you
have been part of the biggest ever yeah
when i came to england in 1994
part of the deal was they gave me a
grant to study to put together a huge
sample of 10
000 pairs of twins at birth from birth
10 000 pairs of twins 20 000 people
yeah one one percent of all twin births
are twins
and there's say 7 500 births a year at
least there was back then when i started
this 25 years ago
so that's you know just about what you'd
expect and a third of those are
identical
all around the world and that means
two-thirds are non-identical
so um we studied these kids 14 times
between the ages
of infancy at two through
adulthood at 25. we most recently
studied them at 25.
they're all born in 94 95 and 96.
so we started with about 21 000
sets of twins we excluded some because
of illness
especially death we spent a lot of time
making sure we didn't contact
imagine if you had a new
twins and one of them died it wouldn't
be too cool to get a message saying oh
would you like to participate in this
exciting new study of twins
so we spent a lot of time making sure we
didn't do that
and so we ended up with about 85 percent
participation rates which in this sort
of
study you know is is amazing but that's
because parents of twins know they're
special
and is this sorry is this just in the uk
yeah
okay so where we are it's just england
and wales scotland had their own thing
okay is there any criticism around the
fact that the heritability that is
represented
in england and wales wouldn't scale
across the rest of the world
now it's a great question because
remember i said we're describing what is
in a particular population at a
particular time
so it's an empirical question but there
have been studies around the world
there's been three million pairs of
twins studied around the world
in about three thousand different
reports
and it could be the results are very
different
but it turns out they're not very
different
and you know that's really remarkable
and i always talk i study cognitive
abilities and
in india you have studies in rural india
where people are mostly illiterate
and then you have very urban societies
in india the results don't change much
you know they're still coming up with
very substantial heritability
and it didn't have to be that way and
it'd be quite interesting if it weren't
that way
but on balance it's quite the most
remarkable finding
in uh in relation to your point
is that the results are so similar
across many
very different countries did you find or
see any
groups which are less heritable is there
an area on the planet that
seems to be statistically decreased
well the one that's been of interest
in the last decade or so is
not different populations but
within a population the thought that
kids from very deprived backgrounds
lower
socioeconomic status backgrounds
the heritability is lower
is what what they were saying and it
kind of makes sense because you think
the environment is so overwhelming
you know at the extreme and uh
yeah all right and so that was an
interesting notion but there's been a
dozen studies since
and they generally don't confirm it the
one thing that's left is
the guy who found it initially is in
america he's done several subsequent
studies where he says he still finds it
and so the possibility exists that maybe
it's less heritable for low ses kids in
america
but not in the rest of the world which
is europe
australia southeast asia and you know
again it would be a great story if it's
true i'm kind of dubious that it's true
this is a guy kind of hanging on to a
finding that everybody wanted to believe
because it's a really cool finding you
know gene environment interaction
the idea of different strokes for
different folks but um
it could make sense because in the us
um it's the most decentralized education
system
in the uh develop the world
so every little school district they
just make all their own decisions
so you could imagine that creates a lot
of
environmental variance and then you
could imagine that the kids in the
lowest ses
schools are in the bottom of that pile
perhaps
so if it were true it'd be interesting
so i guess
the point i'm making i don't have any i
don't have any skin in this game of
trying to say
it's the same result everywhere in fact
i find it really interesting if we could
find
groups or countries where the results
are very different
doesn't seem to be that way though okay
so how
how do genes influence our behavior like
is there a violin playing gene in a
premature ejaculation gene and a dog
loving gene
yeah that's what people tend to think
about you say genetic and they think
single gene well for the single gene
disorders it is a single team
you know i mean huntington's we know
pretty much what that gene does and how
it affects the
the brain it starts creating
um we call them repeat sequences but you
know it
it messes up the gene by reproducing not
what it's supposed to reproduce but
extra bits
and those extra bits just start mucking
up the proteins it creates
and then eventually the brain just
starts to
degenerate as a result of having all
this muck around
but when you get into complex traits and
common disorders like heart disease or
um or obesity or psychological traits
there's no example of a single gene
disorder
and if there are thousands of genes
involved
each contributing a tiny bit of risk
um what are the chances you're going to
find an intervention
that works because you know people still
think of the brain
in this kind of simple-minded
neurologizing way
this does that this bit of the brain
does that but
you know i think if there's thousands of
genes they're going to work at the level
of the brain
and they're going to make it very
difficult to find any pathways
it's just you know and which kind of
makes sense you know from an
evolutionary perspective
you if you want to have a species evolve
you're not going to just say oh well
let's make it simple for neuroscientists
and have
this one simple pathway that makes all
the difference
that would be disastrous really what you
would do as natural selection is take
advantage of all the dna differences
that are there
and you'd select for behavior you'd
select
for people who are say brighter and
solve
problems more quickly and you take
advantage of
all the dna variation that exists
everywhere not even just in the brain in
the body as well
so i i think it does make sense it it's
a it's not a happy story
for molecular biologists who want to do
a reductionistic approach to gene
this gene does this and that does this
in the brain
and then that causes this in behavior so
but as a psychologist i'm interested in
the behavior you know
and um so it's okay by me
and what's exciting now is we can
predict these behavioral differences
with dna itself i guess what you're
saying there the fact that it's
uh it provides a challenge for
interventions what you're
referring to is that if you wanted to go
in and edit
the genes to make someone a thing if you
wanted to try and manifest a trait
you don't just get to go and poke one of
them you actually have to poke a lot of
them and i'm guessing that the ten
percent
that you're now able to predict bmi
uh in life is because you've managed to
bundle together
around about one-fifth of the genes that
are
uh responsible for causing that weight
yes yes
well i agree with the second part of
what you said about the first part it
makes interventions difficult i don't
think so
because an important um
i don't know if it's a law but i mean
for me it's just about a law
is that cures aren't necessarily related
to causes
now you always think if you find out a
cause then
you fix it now that's true with single
gene sorts of things
it's true with single environmental
agents like
sars um two and covid you only get covid
if you get infected with this virus
so you wanna know who has it who doesn't
have it it's dichotomous and then
you pick the people who've got it and
you think well what can we do
to prevent other people from getting it
to make the course of the illness less
bad
to stop people from dying so you know
definitely knowing the cause helps a lot
in knowing the cure but now what if you
take common disorders and psychological
traits
where we've got thousands of genetic
differences
there is no single cause there's a whole
gamish of causes and i think it's going
to be very difficult
to have these causes tell you what to do
about cures
but fortunately cures don't are often
most often not related to causes so if a
kid has a reading disability
neuroscientists often think
they're looking for the hole in the
brain they're looking for the bit of the
brain
that misfires you know and
um long stories there but if there's
thousands of dna differences involved i
think
it's just some kids have more trouble
learning to read it's not that they're
dyslexic you know if you want to make
medicalize it you give it a greek or
latin name
and then then you say i'm sorry madam
your child has
dyslexia you don't say they have reading
problems because a psychologist could
tell them that
and similarly with hyperactivity you
don't say your kid has poor attention
span you say
your kid has hyperkinetic disorder
you know because it medicalizes it and
then you think there's a simple cause
and then you think there's going to be a
simple cure what people like is giving
the name to it
wrangles the chaos into order right okay
it's a thing
i know that it's a thing i think you've
got a quote that says there are no
disorders
there are just quantitative dimensions
yes
that's this bumper sticker of the normal
the abnormal is normal
what the genetics suggest is that more
than suggests it really i think
necessarily implies that if there's
thousands of genetic differences
affecting a trait like reading
disability
those genes are normally distributed so
some people
have a lot just by chance of those dna
differences that make it more likely
that they'll have problems learning to
read doesn't mean that you're going to
have reading
disability or be diagnosed with it just
it's a propensity
and what i like about this is it it's
going to be the nail in the coffin of
diagnosis
so in medicine the illness model
medical model you know work really well
when you've got simple causes
so you want to find out what causes
cholera someone figures out it's
bugs in the water you know and then you
stop the bugs in the water and you cure
this
but it doesn't work that way for common
disorders or quantitative traits
and although it might make people feel
better to say ah i know why i've been
having so much trouble in life
i have dyslexia you know or whatever
and it but it's it's the truth has got
to be better and that is
that there is no it's just all
quantitative it's not a matter of either
or
to drive that home there's no point
along this normal distribution
at which after this point somebody
becomes labeled
dyslexic or dyspraxic or whatever it
might be
there are a whole bundle of traits that
are normally distributed some people
have a particular
combination of those which has created a
meal and that meal
is a restriction in their ability to
read but
as we said before that could come from a
number of different pathways as well
the same ways you can gain weight by not
lighting exercise or by liking food too
much or by doing both or by any other
number of things
you can be not very turned on by reading
or you can find it hard or you can
struggle to gain vocabulary or you can
do
and then the medicalization that you've
got where you give particular
terminology
what you're doing is bundling common
disorders or orders
into a title which combines those traits
together
and and that's the outcome that you get
and it's dichotomous you know
it's you are or you aren't yes you are
you aren't and what's bad
what i like about this normal
distribution this quantitative
idea is that it's not like those
schizophrenics
and us normal people you know we all
have thousands
of genetic risk factors for
schizophrenia it's just a question of
how many you have and how you
interact with the environment because
even if you have a very high score it
doesn't mean you're necessarily going to
be schizophrenic
partly because we're only explaining
about 15 percent of the liability
to become schizophrenic so it's not
deterministic it's probabilistic
but i there's a lot of advantages to
thinking about these things
quantitatively
because you're not trying to cure a
disorder there's no disorder you're not
trying to cure it
you're trying to alleviate symptoms
quantitatively
you know the the the the output here
what you want to do is not just say okay
they're cured
it's not going to happen you know and so
there's many ways in which i think it is
important i think this medical model
has been holding back psychological
research
i want to give you a list of a bunch of
different things that i've come up with
and we're going to see if you know how
heritable they are if they are or if
they aren't
well they all will be as we've already
already identified uh so aggression
or anti-social behavior stuff like that
yeah well that's an interesting one
aggression it's hard to measure but if
you just do it the usual way with
self-report personality questions
most personality measures including
aggression
are less heritable than other traits
like cognitive traits they're about 40
percent heritable i mean
40 50 not much difference but
you know it's not a hundred percent it's
not eighty percent and it's not ten
percent or twenty it's
you know it's substantial but it's not
the whole story but
psychopathy is interesting because early
in life
it seems to be very highly heritable and
you wouldn't think you could measure it
early in life it's not these are the
kids who
my colleague essie viding at ucl has
studied this for a long time
it's more technically called um callus
unemotional psychopathy these are the
kids who tear wings off flies
though they'll hurt animals not not
because they like to hurt
things it just it doesn't you know it
doesn't bother them
and so psychopaths aren't out to hurt
you
either even as adults they want
something and if you're in the way
you know they'll push you aside because
it just
there's no empathy there so i think
that's a really
interesting one and it remains uh
it's not shown but early in childhood
it's very highly heritable
then when you get into middle adulthood
it gets mixed up with delinquency
which is almost normative shoplifting
you know doing stuff
when you're an adolescent destroying
vandalizing property
yeah i'm not saying it's a good thing
but you know so many kids do it some
people have said
it's actually predictive of better
mental health later but that's a
different story
but the point is these kids who are
cruel and
doing bad things they get sucked up into
this adolescent delinquency thing
but then they come out the other end
being more psychopathic whereas
the normative sort of usual delinquent
behavior in adolescence tends to drop
out
okay iq that is one of the more highly
heritable traits it's
probably it's interesting over the
lifespan well first of we used to say
it's 50 heritable but almost all those
studies involve
kids just because it's easier to study
twins and adopt these when they're
living at home
but then when you got to um adults
you find that the inheritability of iq
increases linearly throughout the
lifespan
20 in infancy 40 in childhood like the
early school years
60 in young adulthood and some people
say even 80 percent
later in life now that's really
interesting how can heritability change
but it makes the point we're just
describing differences as they exist
in a particular sample and so if you
look at young
samples versus old samples heritability
now
consistently we've done meta-analyses
across all these that consistently goes
up in an almost linear way
why do you think that is well it nobody
knows for sure
i think and i think most people think
it's because
genetics isn't it isn't like
hardwired in the brain it's not
what it is it makes you use your
environment differently
so if you if you study these really
bright young kids
and say what are they doing it's they're
asking questions they go into a room and
they wonder
about the angles at the corners of the
room
you know they just use their environment
in a better way
they get a lot more information out of
it the classroom is a good
the teachers can teach something to kids
but some kids will get so much more out
of it than others
and i think as you go through life then
you it's called this is called gene
environment correlation as you go
through life
it's not that it's not that the
heritability is there at the moment of
conception
you know and it doesn't change it it
makes you
use your environment differently so that
you select environments
modify them and create environments
correlated with your genetic
propensities
so kids who are academically oriented
they hang out with other academically
oriented kids
they read books they're interested in
intellectual things
whereas other kids have other appetites
and increasingly i think it's
appetites it's not aptitudes it's not
this hardwired
you know brain that's making the
difference
it's just these sort of psychological
appetites it's what you like and what
you like you do
and you tend to get better at that so
that the differences snowball until
later in life
you know i see my parents were 97 until
they died a couple years ago
and they were in an old people's home
and you really see the differences there
i mean some of these older people are
still very active intellectually
you know they don't lobotomize
themselves on television
they argue with people they read the
newspapers
you know they're really alive and the
differences seem to be even greater
you know later in life so i think that's
what happens it's snowballing these
little genetic effects become bigger and
bigger
as you go through life selecting and
modifying and even creating environments
that are correlated with your genetic
propensities
are there any traits that do the reverse
of that um we don't know of any
so when heritability changes it goes up
some people say that's true for body
weight as well
um most of the time like personality
there's no evidence that heritability
changes
across the lifespan so um
it just anyway so cognitive ability is
more heritable than personality maybe 60
percent
academic outcomes is that the same no
it's not you know the correlation
between
how well you do at school in your iq is
about 0.5 in
hundreds of studies that have looked at
this
but um one thing that's interesting is
in the early school years
educational achievement which in england
is great you know we have these
national tests not great for the kids
maybe but it's great for researchers
because
you know they're the most tested kids in
the world so you get very good
educational achievement data at least
for what tests are measuring
and they're substantially more heritable
in the first school years like 60
heritable as compared to iq which is 40
percent heritable
and i think that's really interesting
but educational achievement stays at
about 60
heritability all the way through gcses
and a levels whereas
iq is going up and up and up and they
cross
somewhere in adolescence ah that's so
interesting
so you don't have as much of an increase
in heritability over time with academic
outcomes as you do with iq
yes and so um yeah again i don't know
why
but i wonder if it this raises
brings it's worth going into this like
why is that because
it raises another issue i think that's
important and
that is that i think what educational
achievements what teachers teach we have
a national curriculum and their
teachers have to teach certain things on
certain days you know it's very
prescribed
and so kids who come to school without
much background they very quickly
do their phonetics get into reading but
no one
teaches iq i think they ought to
because iq is general reasoning abstract
reasoning
the scientific method i think and i
think we need a
heavy dose of that people need to
recognize the importance of
thinking logically and taking new facts
and coming up with hypotheses and
realizing
you don't believe them you test them and
you have to test them
so i think that has a lot to do with iq
we don't teach it so as a result i think
when kids come to school
you know um they're
well they're not um
they're not getting the the full
possibilities for
expressing their genetic propensity so
again it's just that
again we're describing what is in a
particular population in this case
the early school years the you know and
then going on through key stage two
three four
um and one thing i'll mention is you
know michael gove when he was a
secretary of education uh what almost a
decade ago now
he instituted this idea of a phonetic
screening test
you know a lot of the stories they think
it's uh whatever was
in the 50s the good old glory days
that's what's got to be good
and they taught reading by phonetics
there and somehow in the 60s and 70s
educators began to teach reading through
word recognition
and you know recognizing whole words and
not worrying so much about spelling and
phonetics well
so michael gove said teachers got to
teach phonetics
and he instituted this test a
four-minute test
of phonetics and it's really kind of a
cool test two minutes
where you read age-appropriate words at
seven they're like dog cat
you know and and then as fast as you can
as many words as you can
in two minutes and then there's a list
of matched non-words so these are not
words
they're like tep tep um
yep you know gep they're phonetically
and linguistically matched
but the only way you can say what the
word is if you can sound it out
phonetically
and so michael gove thought this is
going to be a test of how well the
teachers are teaching and he was going
to name and shame those schools that
didn't do phonetics
it's the most heritable test we have so
at seven when these kids have to take
this test that test
is 70 percent heritable
which is amazing given that it was no
one even questioned this they said well
okay
it's a phonetics test so kids didn't
learn phonetics
by themselves so this is a test of how
well the teachers have taught phonetics
but instead what it says is some kids
pick it up a lot better than others
i'm convinced there's individual
differences all over the place i bet you
there are some kids who would learn to
read better
with whole word reading but we force all
these different shape
pegs into this one round hole
of the national curriculum and i think
that's the
biggest lesson to learn in education and
teachers
know it you can't stand in front of a
class of 30 kids and not recognize
that some of them pick stuff up very
fast
and others just need a lot more help so
i'm particularly keen on education
because that's the business end
of these cognitive abilities so i keep
distracting you we just said iq
all right so next one but 50 heritable
law
on average next one penis size did
anyone research penis size
there have been studies on it but i'm
not aware of genetically um
sensitive studies shame someone should
do that diabetes
yeah that's been studied a lot and it's
maybe
it's tricky when you're dealing with
these disorders
diabetes isn't a disorder it's a
quantitative trait
right and um
so many of these disorders are like
heart disease they're not
disorders so hypertension these are
pretty normally distributed traits
and things that work work quantitatively
too
so when you've got a dichotomy it makes
it much more difficult to say how
heritable it is
because all you've got is a zero and a
one at what point does diabetes become
diabetes
well but you take it for what it is and
then you create
these very complicated statistics called
liability
but it's a liability to the disorder
because you recognize it's not really a
disorder
but if you look at simple concordance
you know that's like
if one identical twin has schizophrenia
what's the chance that the other one
does
and even though you don't believe it's a
dichotomy like that
and the answer is about 50 the identical
twins are similar and
non-identical twins their concordance
for a diagnosis of schizophrenia
is very much lower about seven percent
now they're they're half as similar
genetically as identical twins so you
would have expected them
to be about 25 similar because identical
twins are 50
similar but they're only 5 but it's just
because in a way because
these things are not very useful
statistically when you're dealing with a
dichotomy it makes it
makes it trickier but the evidence is
still very clear that genetics is
important
what about a happiness set point or sort
of self-reported
uh life happiness well
there's a lot of work about um
depression and
um well-being which is what a lot of
people
mean by happiness a sense of well-being
it's all a tricky business but if you
look across all those studies
they're about 40 percent heritable when
you measure them quantitatively
at least with happiness you're not
saying people are either happy or not
so you measure it quantitatively and
when you do
for well-being you find that about
40 of the differences between people can
be ascribed to these inherited dna
differences
that's crazy when you think about how
much work people put into trying to make
themselves happy
you know it's one of the the most common
conversations that
podcasts have i actually actually quite
err away from having it on this show
especially after reading your book but
also generally it's just a bit of an
icky topic to me to talk about
happiness and this generation of it as
if that's the only thing really that
people should be aiming for in the world
there's a lot of other contributing
factors to the sense of well-being have
you got meaning in your life do you have
connections
when does that become happiness so on
and so forth yeah
yeah yeah i suggest people do some
meditation training or something you
know to recognize that
you don't become happy you've only got
this instant
you be and you either you can be happy
be here now that
sort of thing i mean as hokey as these
things sound like we mentioned sam
harris we were talking before and
you know i think his app waking up app
is it's really changed my life in a lot
of ways i
i was in philosophy and and i i took
against it because it's not empirical
um i can go into that a bit but
psychology is actually
the empirical side of philosophy but it
can only deal with things you can test
right psychology is the empirical side
of philosophy i like that
right what was because i was at a place
at depaul university in chicago
that specialized um in phenomenology
now that's the branch of philosophy that
talks about
the is-ness of things like the deskiness
what is it that's the essence of a desk
you know okay fair enough
but after i heard this about the third
time i kept saying well
there's these huge arguments about it
and saying how do you know this guy is
right or that guy's right
there's got to be some way to test it
and i ran into a stone wall because
i realized finally that if you can test
it
it's no longer philosophy and i ask what
is it it's psychology
if you can actually test it so at that
point i decided great i'll go into
psychology which is what i did
and i've i've sort of been
anti-philosophy
you've come full circle now i have yeah
maybe that's the
result of getting older or meeting sam
harris and
you know it's not the you know
philosophy
went bad in the 70s it went into
linguistics and
you know it's not like i'm really into
stoicism which
is the most ancient um philosophy around
confucianism and i think it's very
practical psychology
what they're talking about there well
modern philosophy
you know is not that i mean it's really
dealing with this very abstract
mathematical linguistic sort of stuff
fine you know everybody do their own
thing
but there's got to be room here for
philosophy in the old
sense you know the ethical and moral and
what does it mean to be human and how
can i
be happy or become happy and you know
so i think it's a great point and um
having said that uh i agree completely
you know that people are obsessed with
becoming happy
and that's a losing proposition in a way
you know the stoics talk about this
william irving has written some
great stuff about stoicism and
he the stoics you know talking
about many many centuries ago they
talked about hedonic adaptation
and if you live life because you'll just
be happy if you can get
x y or z the new car the new house the
new job
but then you get it and yeah you're a
little bit happier for a while but then
there's
hedonic adaptation you get used to it
and again
it's not making you happy in fact if it
could have made you happy if something
could have made you happy
you've been spending your life trying to
be happy and it hasn't made you happy
you might get the idea trying to
get what you don't have is not the way
to go and the stoics say
it's the other way it's to say
use these techniques like negative
visualization
to want what you have
and to realize what you have you may
think is [ __ ] but
he'll say there's about a billion 10
billion billions of people on earth
who would do anything to trade lives of
a few
but that's the thought experiment right
like that the things that you now
have those which only once you dreamt of
and when you actually when you reframe
stuff like that yeah i am
i had rupert spyra on the show recently
non-dualism guy
and uh i found him very very clear
and precise with how he put across
non-dual non-duality as a philosophy
which is it can get a bit
get a bit messy at times i'm still
having trouble with that you know
i'm struggling with sam harris that's a
new whole lecture series by someone
on this i think it might be rupert so
he's definitely
you're exactly right it is very softly
spoken british man
exactly i started listening to that
today okay even with sam
i still have trouble with the site maybe
i have too big an ego
to deny myself separate yourself from
the experience yeah well i mean
so the episode uh will be out so i'll
send it i'll send it to you once it goes
up but um
yeah and he he used this word and it
really got to me he used the word
happiness
he was talking about the fact he said
that the natural state of humans
once you strip away the the egos the
preconceptions blah blah blah blah blah
is happiness and i had a real problem
with it because i felt like
happiness to me is something in motion
it didn't feel like a stripping away it
felt like an
action it felt like momentum and rupert
said
he would be happy to interchange that
for peace and i was like uh okay
so for me the word if what he means by
happiness is peace
absolutely fine with that like that's a
still that's a still car motion
or a clear sky as opposed to happiness
which is like there's a boat in the
ocean or there's a plane in the sky
um so eddie we've we've got sidetracked
last two i've got two more for you
um is infidelity heritable have you ever
been able to look at this
um well david buss you know studied a
good friend of mine
from an evolutionary perspective but um
divorce has been studied and that shows
heritable influence
do you know how much uh not you know not
a lot maybe 30 percent or so
it's quite a lot yeah um
and again it's not because you have
genes for divorce you know you say that
there's heritable influence on divorce
people say the divorce
gene or you talked about aggression the
warrior gene
for example it's not that it's like
what makes people get divorced well
i think a lot of it has to do with um
joie de vivre good things
you know you get maybe you get bored
you're a sensation seeker or
you just really like the fireworks of
love and romance these may have been the
things that made someone attractive in
the first place
but it could be that those same things
make them
more at risk for
[Music]
divorce so i don't know of a study of
infidelity i'm sure there are some
though but it's not something i've
looked into
what about sexual preference the gay
gene is something that people have
talked about for a very long time what
does
how does this come out in the research
well see that got started you know when
the dna revolution was just happening it
was way premature
and it wasn't true you know that there's
a gay gene
but um michael bailey at notre dame has
done most of the work on this and
there's
there is genetic influence on sexual
preference
and i know some people get very upset
about that
but um i think most gays are happy to
accept that because
it means it isn't just
a lifestyle fashion choice yeah exactly
yeah
which in the current identity politics
day it seems to be
getting to be more more like that but
there is a genetic component i worked at
an adolescent treatment center where we
had three
um gay boys when i was in graduate
school
and you know they just tell you their
story from early in life they just
really knew they were different and they
hid it they tried their best to be
daddy's boy and everything and then
fortunately and by the 60s or so
it got a little bit easier for people to
come out
so again i think it's important to
recognize there is a genetic
tendency it doesn't mean everybody who
is gay
has this genetic tendency it's just
overall in
the population of gays there does seem
to be a genetic
propensity but it doesn't mean you're
determined it's not hardwired it's just
like all these other traits
the thing that i'm interested in here
when
talking about the genes is is a child's
behavior
like an aggregate of their pe how their
parents behavior manifests
so or can you have genetic influences on
behavior which kind of come out of
nowhere so could you have two very calm
parents
whose dna combines to make an easily
prone to anger or violence child
obviously
we're talking on average here yeah well
it's a good point because a lot of
people think well you get your genes
from your mother and your father
so surely you have to be a blend between
them
but the thing is these are discrete
units that's what mendel figured out
long ago
genes don't just blend they're
they they're discrete so you can have
zero one or two
we call them alleles form of a of a
particular gene
now you look at polygenic scores that
involve thousands of these
those scores will be normally
distributed
within a family and we can show this and
we've always known this to be true
so that means that um say
parents where one is very highly
educated and the other isn't
it's not like the kids are all going to
be in between they're going to have a
whole range
of individual differences including some
that are some of the brightest
you know they have the highest genetic
scores and some that have the lowest
and what i like about this is there's a
concern about right now about genetic
castes
you know like the indian caste system
and the idea is that
by meritocracy is getting us into
genetic cast because the silicon valley
people marry each other
and they have these super bright kids
but what's i don't think it's true
as long as there is mobility because
if say two parents iq is a
mean of 100 and we call standard
deviation of 15.
so it means if you're at the 85th
percentile um
you have an iq score and out of 100 but
of like 115
and two standard deviations an iq score
of 130.
the average iq of people with phds is
130. so suppose you have two parents
with iqs of 130.
what's going to be the average iq of
their kids it's not 130
it's 115. it's 50 heritable
so the kids will regress to the
population mean of a hundred
so on average they'll have a
considerably lower iq than their parents
and and then secondly there's this big
distribution of scores
kids in a family with the same parents
have
genetic scores that differ a lot not as
much as anybody
any random people in the population but
a whole lot so that
you can get kids in the same in a family
with the same parents
where one is genetically has got all the
goods and the other doesn't and
this is really comes home to me because
my my sister never liked school
never that was late to learn to read
didn't like to read still doesn't much
like to read
whereas i read early not because my
parents didn't have anything to do with
this
neither of them went to high school they
just barely finished high school in the
depression in the united states
so just on my own i started reading even
before i went to school i got books from
the library
and i always loved school because it was
easy i was good at it
and you know got rewards for it my
sister just didn't like it
and yet we have the same parents we have
the same nurture
and people say well but you've got the
same genes too when we don't we can show
this now with the dna
and you know i think it's an important
point to recognize that when
university-educated parents have kids
who don't want to go to university and
it's like the end of the world
but then do we want to force kids in you
know with all their different shapes
into these around
this one round hole of this golden
yardstick of academics
i think there's a big movement now away
from that
um so we might talk more about that
later yeah it's so interesting
that that point i never even realized
that
you as a set of parents providing traits
to your child
you're you're competing or you're sort
of almost aggregating them against where
the
center of that normal distribution for
the population is so if you're an
outlier on either side of that it's
either going to drag down or drag
up on average from wherever you are
yes and and then the other part of it
though is that there'll be a big range
of your kids don't all have that one
mean score everyone's 115 iq yeah yeah
no and um i think that's hard for some
parents to accept like with my sister
who
thought well you know she just wasn't
trying hard enough
but you know again it's appetizing she
just didn't like it you know she just
didn't like academic
training she went on to do a good life
she was a lab tech in a hospital she did
save people's lives by doing these blood
tests very carefully and
and she's very good with you know fine
motor stuff she just likes that
and she's good at it and the world's a
better place for it
all right so outside of genetics what
are the other influences on our
behavior how do they slot together
um so you're talking about the 50 of the
differences that aren't due to genetics
that's the other big story that we
haven't touched on
because psychology for a century just
assumed everything's nurture
the way you are is the way your parents
treated you
you know i mentioned schizophrenia
before but also kids do well at school
because they have parents who did well
at school why is that well parents
help them to do well at school it's all
environmental
well now we know half of the differences
are not are genetic
they have that aren't genetic are not
what we thought they were they're not
due to these
systematic effects of parenting
two they make two kids in the same
family as different as kids in different
families
so the environment's important but it's
not this nurture the systematic effects
of the environment
that psychologists always assumed was so
important
and i know it's hard to get your head
around that but
you can you can see it in many different
types of studies
but the easiest way to see it is
adoptive families
a third of them adopt a second child so
these two kids are genetically unrelated
to each other
but they grow up in the same family well
for iq
siblings correlate about 0.3 in
childhood about 0.4
later on how much do these adoptive sibs
correlate because they grow up in the
same family they have the same parents
zero so that's
so the fact of growing up in the same
family isn't making them similar
yet the environment's important and what
is it
we call it non-shared environment that
is
it's something that's not shared it's
not shared by kids growing up in the
same family
so you can start to think of things once
you start thinking this way you got to
ask
what makes kids in a family different
and you can think of things like peers
you know when you kids get into
adolescence you can see that makes a
difference
accidents illnesses things like that
but after 30 years of looking for these
things we haven't found them
so one of the points of my book
blueprint is i've come to conclude
what's called the gloomy prospect i
don't think it's so gloomy but it's just
it's the role of chance that
of the important environmental factors
are sort of idiosyncratic
you know they're we call it stochastic
chance events so um i was thinking bill
clinton
says he got into politics because at the
age of 16
he shook jfk's hand john f kennedy's
hand
and that just really made him say i you
know i want to go into politics
i mean maybe it's just a retrospective
history but there are events like that
where
you know when people do their
autobiographies and they look back on
their lives
they say ah that was a real turning
point that teacher at school that
biology teacher
or this event where i was humiliated in
the playground or
you know there are these events that you
can't just
measure because they're kind of unique
to an individual at a particular time
that's what i mean by idiosyncratic it's
the sliding doors sort of phenomena
there's several
current books out current novels one
that i just finished today is called the
midnight library which is uh by matt
hegg
h-a-a-i-g he was the guy who wrote what
is it
uh 20 reasons not to die he's a
depressive
but this book is about alternative
endings and
you know how things could just change a
little bit
but then that is a tipping point that
leads to
other things and it could end up very
differently lionel schreiber's new book
too
is um about that about alternate endings
in life so i think um and there's a
great book by melvin king who is the
former
bank of england head um that that's
called um
uh not random chance what is it called
uh oh shoot i'm blocking it's a great
word but
um it's like super chance you know
it's that we need to recognize that
chance plays a much larger life
role in life physicists are getting into
this too
you know the idea that things are
essentially
unpredictable in at some level and i
think it's good for us to know that like
in matt haig's book the woman who wanted
to commit suicide and
goes to this library and tries out
alternate lives ends up coming back to
her own
life having realized that every life
could go many different ways
and it's again what we're talking about
with meditation it's
all you've got is what you're
experiencing this instant everything
else is either
a thought or a memory that came
from it's it's you know it's sensations
it's not you that created these things
these are just sensations
in your brain so i don't know maybe i
i i know you might think i've been
taking some psychedelics or something
no i know i get it i mean i like it when
these things all come together like that
i agree yeah the synchronicity is
beautiful and it lends credence to the
theory as well right that if you have
these particular
narratives that coalesce it's the same
as when people talk about buddhism and
stoiism and
stoicism and meditation and new world
practice and confucianism
you go okay well if multiple different
parties from different
times from different geographic areas
with different cultures all arrive at
similar sort of
conclusions you probably got a fairly
good amount of backup that that might be
right
exactly right and that's why i'm
resolved
to get a sense of non-dualism but i'm
having a hell of a time
out of a few months but um i find it
really difficult but i'm beginning to
see at least sam harris is saying
you don't get it all at once you know it
comes some people have an epiphany
but for most people you just get it a
little bit more and a little bit more
but it's exactly as you say i mean every
ancient philosophy comes up with this
it's all the ego there is no self yeah
be
present find happiness in the moment
yeah all of these different things you
so
you saw right so this the my favorite
sentence
in the entire book that i think kind of
drives this home so we've
put people into a coffin we've put a
couple of nails in and then this is the
dirt that goes on top i think
saying parents matter but they don't
make a difference
what does that mean well i'm i'm glad i
think are you saying you liked it or
oh i loved it i this is i live for this
stuff yeah
right um because uh that's the
four pages in the book that have by far
gotten the most attention so much so
that i was going to write another book
that would just focus on genetics and
parenting
are you a parent uh no uh-huh but um
uh when you become a parent or you know
people who are parents
there are thousands literally thousands
of parenting books they don't mention
genetics
whereas i have no doubt that genetics
is the single most important thing that
parents need to know
that is not that it's all deterministic
not that they can't do anything about it
but they have much less control over
their kids
outcomes than they think they have
because genetics is genetics
and the environment isn't the
environment we thought it was
it's not if it's chance and stochastic
events
idiosyncratic events parents don't have
control over that
so i think they need to relinquish
control to a greater extent
and to fight spend more time figuring
out what their kid likes to do
and what they're good at and helping
them do it rather than
preordaining my kids going to be an
olympic athlete or
a professional musician it's not that
you can't do it
you know the tiger moms he shows you can
make kids do stuff
to a certain extent but why i think it's
it's analogous to like if you
if you have a partner and you pick them
because you say well there's some pretty
good raw material here but i'm going to
make them into
what i really want them to be you know
it's a disaster because
you have relationships because you love
people and when you love people
you want to do good things for them you
want life to be nice for them
on their terms and so same with
kids i think you know it's better to
focus on your relationship it's a long
relationship
and some of this tiger parenting or
helicopter parenting
is counterproductive to the relationship
and so i just think it's better for
parents to realize they don't have
nearly as much control as they think
they have and it's better to go with the
flow
it's not to say you can't change things
but it's
awfully good to recognize what kids
their appetites as well as their
aptitudes and to help them do what they
want to do to be
like a resource manager to give them
opportunities to find out what they like
to do
so is there a way to get off the soapbox
now
is there a way to game the stochastic
idiosyncratic model well i think
it's partly what meditation is about is
to realize that things that happen to
you they're just happening
there are these events in the world they
don't have anything to do with you
there's a things that are happening
and you you know you don't want to um
read too much into them you just say
like the stoics would say this is a
challenge they talk about stoic
challenges
instead of just saying oh god not again
this is happening to me
i've lost my job or i have to go on
furlough i've got coded you know you can
take that and say uh
life is crap or the stoics would say
think about it as a challenge you know
and do do what you can with what you've
got
is their motto and do it now and make a
plan
and don't waste your time with negative
emotions because they don't do any good
i was talking more from the
uh perspective of the parent so let's
say
that this there are these chance
incidents which occur in young people's
lives they can shape them in
unbelievably dis proportionate ways
as a parent presumably one of the things
that you could
look to do with your child there would
be a big difference between a parent who
sends their child to the same
routine week in week out for 18 years
and a parent that
encourages the child to do a bunch of
different things the outcomes
have to be different for that child
because
the number of opportunities for
different idiosyncrasies and stochastic
inference events to occur is wildly
different the one that
does go and do summer camp and every
summer for you know throughout all of
the years of school and
the one who is encouraged to go to this
sport and then this one as opposed to
you will be a boxer you will be at this
thing like that
has to have it so what i'm thinking
about is for the parents that are
listening or for the few the people that
want to have kids in the future
what are some of the ways that you think
people could maximize that kind of
uh stochastic advantage i guess well it
is
it seems like oxymoronic to talk about
systematic
unsystematic events this is what we're
doing
i think it's more important for parents
to recognize there's just [ __ ] happens
and stuff will happen
and you know some things so what we're
saying is these things are heritable and
they don't show shared environmental
influence
much at all especially for personality
and psychopathology
and that includes
these parents who are doing what you say
who give their kids lots of
opportunities or don't
but again it's what is rather than what
could be
so if you want your kid to be a sprinter
or
a musician you can get the best
teachers around you can do as much as
you can do
but you got to say at what cost you know
and i don't think we do that enough
and to recognize you're better off going
with the genetic flow than spending a
lot of time
figuring out how you're going to
systematize chance
because you really can't that's a really
really good takeaway i used tiger woods
as an example a lot because he had such
an extreme childhood
and has continued to sport through but
look at the
externalities that he's had in his life
like just hugely public marriage
failures he's fallen asleep on the side
of the road because he's been on
antidepressant drugs he recently rolled
his car and broke like
everything so yeah i think um
you're totally correct the price that
people pay for extreme performance
within narrow domains that they may not
have chosen themselves
especially when it's deployed on them by
a parent in early life
you do not know the potential
externalities
the cost the suffering that's going to
occur from that i love the idea of
genetic
flow of look like i am here to provide
resources to be open to move with the
child to allow them to do what they want
i have some wisdom i can say maybe
trying to do free running off the top of
a building at four years old it's a bad
idea timmy like maybe we'll
you know there are certain things that
you know that are better and worse but
also yeah i
i love the idea of of being sort of like
a kite in the wind right you're holding
the kite you can let it out you can pull
it back
but you allow the kite to kind of choose
its own direction based on where it
wants to go
and you recognize that there's very
different sorts of kites
yes yeah this is interesting first of
all
what kind of kite you've got and what
they like you know rather than
in these parenting books are really
they're bad i mean
you know they what do you disagree with
most about the parenting books
just about everything i mean they mostly
are all implying
that parents are completely in control
and it's always by doctor so-and-so
so they appeal to authority but they
don't appeal the data
very few of these books have any
evidence based there's a few now
starting to come out
but parents think it's really bad for
psychology because all you got to do
is go to the bookshop pick up two books
from that pop psychology shelf about
parenting
and one will doctor so and so will say
things very dogmatically about you must
do this about sleeping and eating
and the other one will say things
dogmatically too
but that are completely different and
neither one is based on evidence
and the evidence is that these things
don't have much of an effect
partly because kids are so different you
know what do you do about night waking i
say the answer is it always depends on
the kid
and you know you sort of go with the
flow of what works for you
and the kid you don't do things because
some doctor so and so
said this is what you must do because
you can bet it's wrong that's a perfect
example you could
create a lifestyle in which you parent a
miserable
and it child is also miserable because
you're trying to fit into some
preconceived idea that's been written
down in a book
yeah you both have an absolutely
miserable year or a couple of years
for the outcome to be the same in the
end in any case
so this is and this starts to get us
toward the reason that i felt it was
liberating
um as long as you can avoid the nihilism
and the fatalism
i think the liberation that you can get
from this is
is really strong i want to put one final
nail in the
environmental coffin which is some of
the work that you did to do with schools
and outcomes between different schools
and obviously being in the uk
with us having such a formalized
education system
key stages and the way that who's what's
the awarding body what's the company
called
um uh what is it um i'm not blocking out
nsq
in any way another one that i mean yeah
i do
i do the ones that create these tests
when you were a kid and you came no no
where they come around and they assess
the schools and they say how well the
schools are
offstage yeah remember when you were a
kid in school if you were british in
school
you used to have to be really really
well behaved and the teacher would
award you afterwards if you'd been super
well behaved so they gave them the
citizens
they don't give you notice when they
come or they give you just notice of the
day before
no way is this like a random drugs test
now it is
yeah i mean in fairness then
you couldn't do a better job assessing
schools they interview the kids the
teachers the janitors
you know parents they observe kids in
the classroom
um you know which might be fake to some
extent but not when you don't have any
notice about it
so i think they're very good ratings but
um
that's that's getting that's in aid of
what you're about to
say right yeah so different schools
different outcomes what did you learn by
looking at that
yeah um
well i guess the the main point here
with ofsted is that
parents change their lives because of
ofsted
it's the essence of these school league
tables
and parents will move house and pay like
a
15 20 premium because that house is in a
better catchment area
so no one had asked how much of a
difference does it make
we know there's average differences
between the schools but if you just take
all the kids in the uk thousand
thousands of kids
and you look at the schools they were in
the ofsted quality ratings they had
how much variance in the gcse scores
say just to start with is due to that
the answer is four percent
and if you correct for socioeconomic
status differences because kids are not
randomly assigned to schools some school
districts have a lot more money than
others
it's one percent with dna alone we can
explain
15 of the variance of gcse scores
so it probably what that's about is that
because ofsted's been around for a while
we've gotten rid of the worst schools so
most schools are pretty much
good enough but then there are these
private schools that have tremendous
resources their kids do a lot better at
gcses but what we also
showed is that there's no added value
of these very expensive private schools
the kids get a whole higher average
grade for gcse
but it's a self-fulfilling prophecy they
select the kids
who do very well at school they
interview them they get bright kids who
are
mature you know stable and motivated
it's a no-brainer these kids are going
to do well at gcse's
the question is how much is added by the
school and the answer is about nothing
now maybe kids have a better life there
and certainly have a lot more resources
but um that it's i really think we
should get rid of
private schools or make them not be
charities unless they take like 50
percent of kids
from uh lower uh who are who are less
advantaged
you know and that's the way these things
started the privates
the you know what we call public schools
here but the fee paying schools
they started that way they were going to
get money from the rich ones to
educate other people and the grammars
they were started very much that way
giving kids a chance
you know who couldn't whose parents
couldn't afford that
so i do think the selective school thing
is
bad because that gets you into
meritocracy as well
and and meritocracy only
comes into the uh issue
when you select if you didn't select
kids
you don't have to select on the basis of
merit which is a bad word
i mean it's talent or skill because they
don't merit anything
genetics is a lottery you know the fact
that you had a particular genetic hand
at birth
nothing to do with you that's just as
much chance as these environmental
events it's all chance really
so it's not merit but um well we could
go on and on about meritocracy but the
main point is if you don't have to
select
don't and there'd be a lot of good
things that would come from getting rid
of selective secondary schools which we
don't have in the rest of europe
really nor in the united states all
right so what we've talked about
here is the implications of the other
partner that you choose and your
genetics
really really influencing the outcomes
that your child gets more so
than the school that you choose more so
than
the way that you bring them up how many
parenting books you decide to read so on
and so forth
what are the implications here for mate
choice then is dna dating a thing
oh it is i mean it was in the last five
years or so it's one of the hotter new
things there's like a 20 or so companies
that add dna to their dating sites
and the problem is that the um dna is
very predictive
well highly predictive of cognitive
things but for personality
it's not very predictive yet yet they're
selling it as if
this is the one objective indicator you
have on dating websites
now there's so it will happen eventually
i mean and it is starting to happen now
i mean if you
it's it it's got some advantages over
just
you know people's own statements which
god knows how
true they are but there's a neat aspect
to this i just wanted to mention
it it's dna dating but there's this
famous biologist
on george church at mit harvard who
is setting up a dating service any
couple that's about to get
hooked up or thinking about having kids
if you send your dna which is just a
cheek swab
you know you just put this cotton bud in
your mouth and
and you get a few cells there he will do
whole genome sequencing that is
not just looking at a few hundred
thousand dna differences but all three
billion base pairs of dna
and the reason he's doing that is
because
um there are thousands of single gene
disorders but most of them thankfully
are very rare
but with whole genome sequencing we
could determine the extent to which you
and your prospective partner have the
same mutation because most of them are
recessive meaning
you need to copy two copies to show it
if you get one
you're a carrier but you and your spouse
will both be carriers for maybe
a half a dozen or so of these very bad
single gene disorders you won't show it
though because you're just a carrier
and you won't show it if your spouse has
different
mutations but what if you have
the same mutation then your kids have a
25
chance of having that disorder and you
can then
prevent it with in vitro fertilization
or whatever
so um eskenazi jews have done this about
10 years now
and they've basically eliminated tay
sachs
we already have to take in the u.s we
have to take blood tests for
sexually transmitted diseases and stuff
you know so there is some testing that
goes on
and i do think you won't even have to
pass laws i mean if if couples become
aware of this
they'll find out and they'll do it
because he'll do it for free
and you have to agree to have your dna
be part of research but you might as
well be part of a
a good academic outfit than one of these
companies
you know that sell your dna for billions
of dollars so i do think that's
something for people to consider
um getting this dna screening because in
the past
you only find out about it when you have
a kid who has the disorder
and then you go to a genetic counselor
it totally doesn't surprise me that
dna dating is a thing because if we
actually look at what the
fitness signals are that we look for in
a partner
all that we're doing there is using very
very hard wired in
evolutionary signals to tell us that so
for instance
david buss i absolutely love him he's
been on the show friend of yours
um he told me that symmetrical faces
are genetically more difficult to
manifest the symmetrical face is
something aesthetically which pleases us
but also it's an indicator of fertility
so is more feminine features in a woman
that if you have larger eyes rather
fuller lips rosier cheeks
that is correlated with higher fertility
so all that you're doing now is as
opposed to using
the way that someone looks which is
quite a refune
statistic you're peering underneath the
hood and you're going okay so what are
the contributing factors that actually
create these traits but there's one big
difference is that evolution
is normative we're talking about the
human species so we're talking about
faces are more attractive when you know
they're symmetrical
or not what i'm talking about is
individual differences
and that's called assortative mating and
in general like attracts light so
taller people you can see tend to be
attracted to each other
the correlation there is about 0.2 but
do you know the trait that shows the
greatest disorder in mating
is iq its correlation is about 0.45
and so people who say oh there's no such
thing as iq
it's just what iq tests may measure
they're doing it they're measuring who's
your partner yeah what's your partner's
iq it's
interesting i mean you know when you go
to a singles bar or something within a
first few sentences i mean you can sort
of tell someone's verbal intelligence
and vocabulary alone is the single most
heritable cognitive measure
pardon me what percentage is that um
it's about
60 70 heritable vocabulary
which is kind of neat because people say
how can that be heritable you you have
to learn
words well the point i've been making is
dna is
these genetic effects are never
hardwired in it just means
you tend i've got one grandchild who's a
star at this she she wants to know
everything about nuances of words
why did you use that word and not that
word and then i have other grandchildren
who say
whatever you know what i mean you know
and who's going to get a better
vocabulary it's that one who's really
keen on the language channel so
um sort of mating is an interesting
phenomenon
and um uh we could talk a lot more about
it but it is interesting that
cognitive abilities is one of the most
highly
the traits that show the most disordered
of mating
that's hilarious so rolling it forward i
don't want to get too deep into the sort
of policy implications for this
but i'm sure that everyone that's
listening has thought to themselves
okay there's a lot of talk about
equality of outcome at the moment
and that if you take what we've learned
today
and apply that to the world that we're
in you could actually roll forward to
find a world where there was zero
environmental inequality but what that
would actually
cause is all the nurture would be out of
the way
every difference would simply be due to
genetics and that seems super unfair as
well
yeah i mean it's such a good point you
know it's
equality of opportunity can be indexed
by heritability because as you say
if you get rid of all the things like
privilege and wealth and access you get
rid of all the environmental differences
you don't get rid of the genetic
differences so of the differences that
remain
they're going to be entirely due to
genetic differences
and it's an interesting especially in
education that's a really interesting
principle in a way for people to get
their heads around
um so i'm glad you raised that point um
but
you said equality of outcomes and the
more fundamental point
is that it's equality of opportunity
that's important
but you're never going to have equality
of outcome
so you can give kids all the same
environment
teachers in the classroom see this all
the time they're going to
differ in their how well they do say in
terms of educational achievement
so equality of opportunity doesn't
translate
into equality of outcome and in fact as
you say
if you achieve equality of opportunity
you actually increase the heritability
of the outcomes
so if heritability is an index of
equality
does this mean that as we improve
societal conditions people will become
more and more entrenched
in their social positions and that
social mobility will slow down have you
thought about this
yeah um it's sort of what we were saying
before about genetic caste people worry
about
silicon valley effect yeah i'm saying at
a genetic level
parents of uh kids will have on average
the kids will have a lower iq than them
and there'll be a wide distribution so
as long as we have social mobility
downwards as well as upwards it will be
okay
but there is evidence to suggest that
you know parents are able to use their
wealth
to help the kids who ordinarily
wouldn't have done so well you know
galton who founded behavioral genetics
in england in the late 1800s had this
phrase
ability will out it means if you've seen
really gifted kids like a musically
gifted kid
you almost can't keep them down i mean
they don't have to have the best
teachers in the world
they'll bang on pots they'll sing to
themselves they'll hang out with friends
who like music i mean now with spotify
and all of that
you know there's no limit to what they
can get on their own so ability will out
but at the lower end it's a reasonable
model of education to say
we should really focus our resources on
the lower end
which is called the finish model where
you do what it takes to get everybody up
everybody up to minimal levels of
literacy and numeracy
because without that you really can't be
a participant
in our increasingly technological
society
so that's a matter of value you know but
um
it is one way of handling this genetics
it's teachers need to recognize kids are
different and they differ genetically
doesn't mean you throw up your hands it
just means you notice those differences
you don't expect them to all do the same
with the same curriculum and i think
you put more energy into the lower end
of the distribution
because at the higher end ability will
out now parents of gifted kids are going
to be screaming
at their screens now but you know i do
believe that and sure you can help the
kids at the higher end too give them
even more opportunities
but basically they'll probably do all
right and if if you have to choose and
maybe we don't
but i'd say the resources really ought
to go into the lower end of the
distribution
have you got any idea where the biggest
impact is can you make a smart kid
smarter easier than you can make a dumb
kid
smart i hate to say the answer is
probably yes
i mean it you know you don't have to do
much with the smartest kids
and they'll just take off so any program
that comes
even like head start in the united
states or what was it called here
early starter you know that program they
had to take kids at three gifted and
talented type thing yeah
well it wasn't even what no it was the
other way it was for kids with lower ses
okay status and in the states it was
called head start and it went on for
20 years or something like that it began
here about 10 years ago in england it's
pretty much fizzled out
and it's fizzled out because it was
meant to give kids from
disadvantaged environments a leg up but
instead
the middle class families figured out
the system
and they got their kids
so you know again it's the bourgeoisie
man so it is hard
i think it's a worthy goal to think
about helping the kids at the lower end
because
you know it just doesn't take much for
the kids at the upper end to do well
you just sort of got to stay out of
their way
what do you think is the implication of
this someone's been introduced to
what we've spoken about today the fact
that behavioral genetics is this huge
kind of
unseen unspoken about influence on
our outcomes in life on our day-to-day
experience
how has this informed the way that you
lead your life and see life and the way
that you tell your sort of research
associates and your students as well to
lead theirs
well i don't tell my we do science you
know
we don't do personal counseling i'm
afraid to say
but um it's a good question um i think
that you can answer it at different
levels but it's just i think the first
step
is just to recognize i mean maybe you
don't readers listeners don't accept it
but
realize there's a huge body of evidence
that says
inherited dna differences account for a
lot of variants it in fact
is the major systematic force making us
who we
are which is why my book is called
blueprint how dna makes us who we are it
should say as individuals
the environment's important but i
believe it's not these systematic
effects we thought were important
so if dna is the major systematic force
making us who we are
we've got to pay attention to it we
ought to listen to our genetic whispers
and realize we're all different and
partly meditation might help you
think about who you are and what you
like and
not being molded by what people want you
to be or
what you think you ought to be and in
the end i think it will make people
happier if they live more harmoniously
with their genetic propensities
again it's not to say you can't struggle
against them you can
i mean like alcoholism no matter what
your genetic risk for alcoholism you
cannot become alcoholic
unless you drink a lot of alcohol over a
long period of time
so you know if you stop drinking alcohol
you can't become alcoholic
so there are definitely things you could
do it's just like me and
body weight though easy to say that for
people who don't have those genetic risk
factors
but for those of us at the front line
you know it's it's really tough
coming home late at night being tired
and just saying oh there's a bag of
crisps
and then it's gone well i think i've
been talking a lot about
releasing the tiller which is a term
from
jed mckenna's book spiritual
enlightenment and what he's talking
about is the tiller attached to the
rudder on a boat a lot of the time
people grip it very hard as if
steering more efficiently would get them
through the current more easily
but when you actually just sort of
release and relax and allow things to
occur
but think about think about the people
that you love to watch on television
or at a sports game or comedians up on
stage or a dancer or even a friend that
just has sort of this
effortless social grace what they're
doing they're not gripping the tiller
they're just there in the moment
i had uh a guy that focuses on the
biology of flo stephen cutler on the
show not long ago
and he said that he thinks ten percent
of the entire world's gdp
is people watching other people in flow
in one form or another whether that be
reading a book or watching a sports game
or supporting somebody on tv or whatever
that might be
and um all of this we talked earlier on
about synchronicity and sort of
different narratives coalescing
and it really feels like this to me like
there really is something to it just
i i was given this cue ages ago by an
embodiment practitioner
that said a lot of the time when we're
focusing especially on a screen we lose
the awareness of our peripheral vision
but for everybody that's listening now
if you just
focus on where your peripherals are
whatever it is that you're doing unless
you're driving
and you just take one breath out and you
go oh my god there is so much more here
i'm so much more relaxed i'm so much
more open to this and i think that
what you're saying here using the
genetic current
what do you want to be interested in
like genuinely what would what would you
like to do you don't need to take
society's preconceptions and norms and
ideas of what you should be doing like
your life can be lived by design
not default and you can also do that in
reverse you can
you can have faith in the embodied
version of you
that will drag me forward and i think
that confidence in ourselves should have
been very much reinforced by what we've
gone through today
well i really agree that kind of brings
us to a good point of closure i think
with the philosophy as well as the
psychology and the genetics
so it's been great talking to you i
really enjoyed it very much there's so
much more to say but that's a
good starter anyway robert it's been
absolutely awesome blueprint will be
linked in the show notes below
where can people keep up to date with
the work that you're doing at the moment
if you've got website or something like
that yep
and i'm easy to find just robert ploman
and
you can google me and i have 900 papers
and 12 books so
you can get sick of me pretty quickly
but there's a lot of new and exciting
stuff that's happening but mostly i do
the hardcore science part of it
but um it's an exciting field and i feel
very lucky to have
been in this field just on on the rocket
ride you know from
where when i started psychology didn't
accept genetics at all
and now most psychologists accept
there's a strong genetic component
and then the dna revolution came along
but we can actually
find the bits of dna that predict these
differences
so it's um it's been a great ride and
it's
um lovely to see the science work out
like that
but again i was just there for the ride
in a way i mean
you know and it's sort of what you're
saying is you know if you're going with
the flow
you can see oops i'm going that way you
know you've got your hand
loosely on the rudder i'm a sailor so i
know exactly what he means the boat
actually knows better than you
if you hold it hard the boat wants to go
up and down the waves a little bit
but if you're making it go straight like
that it doesn't actually sail very well
so i think it's a good analogy a good
metaphor for
life well i appreciate you for um
dragging yourself
out of the illustrious towers of doing
research and coming to
going coming into the trenches to talk
about i think that stuff like this it is
without someone like you like an
academic communicator intellectual who's
able to actually just get this stuff
across in a way that people can
understand
no no one's digging into this research
it's so complex and it would be too
far too hard so you are doing awesome
work and whenever whatever comes out
next comes out book number
325 or whatever it is um i will be
harassing you to bring you back on
robert it's been so good thank you
well thank you chris thank you very much
for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed peace